I have to be with this so I focus on the
statement thinking feely response I'm
able to effectively respond to stress in
my life I swipe and then I wit and I
went three times and then it processes
the sensor data whoa no no one's using
yes it's gonna take a second for the
signal but if you it'll show up in about
a second or two you've got to turn the
servers on they're just feeling stressed
I'm a little nervous when I do public
speaking so boom what's up everyone
welcome to simulation I'm your host
Allen saw queuing we are still on site
at consciousness acting's awake and
future summit we are now gonna be
talking to Mike dan hi hello how's it
going thank you so much for coming on
the show really appreciate it very
excited to talk to you about sensi your
co-founder founder co-founder co-founder
of Scentsy which is the easiest way to
measure how you feel and identify
sources of stress you might be unaware
of with smart phone sensors yes all
right so let's unpack this who are you
what do you represent
that's a good question start with so
Mike Dan Heim
you know I've been building tech
startups for about ten years now
I make consciousness junkie I had a
concussion with retrograde amnesia like
15 years ago where I had an out-of-body
experience and just got obsessed with
consciousness and like how it was that
experience possible you can it's good to
that experience
tell us about this yeah I actually had
two I had one in high school from a
sports injury but then I had a second
one in college from a car accident and
the car accident one was an out-of-body
experience the first one there wasn't an
out-of-body experience but I got this
really bad car accident it was a pile-up
in Philadelphia it was a bunch of cars
and my friend pulled me out of the car I
was unconscious and as I got out of the
car I sort of came back into awareness
and the vantage point was from the back
of the top of my head but I was out of
the body and I could see down and when
the police on this they were on the
scene would speak to me I would toggle
back in and then when it stops beginning
it would go out and it was
there's no and the most important part
was when I was out wherever I was or
whatever the seat was that I was in was
just it was beautiful and it was
peaceful and it was perfect and there
was so much chaos but wherever I was in
that moment and even when I toggle in it
was still very still but when I was
there it was just like whoa and it
looked very very I would do hell for the
next year and a half after that accident
in the recovery but I was still left for
the deep mark of like what was that I'm
like and also how was the body operating
because the body was operating without
my involvement and that left me deeply
curious about this organism and how it's
doing whatever it's doing yeah how how
was it that we somehow found ourselves
outside of of us right and you said you
were kind of going into the body to
engage with the the situation the chaos
but then out and when you were out you
said that it was this feeling of just
just perfectness
perfectly so perfect and another
creation it was really strange was that
when I toggled in there was an hearing
was off for me for some reason you see
like those movies where a bomb goes off
and someone's like talking to the guy
who was near to the bomb and he can see
what's going on but he came to hear it
there's a version of it that he's
hearing that was sort of what I was
hearing was like when I toggle back in
and then when I was out it was perfect
yeah well how old are you 20 21 21 damn
yeah damn and you had a year and a half
of crazy recovery yeah I struggled
really badly with memory-recall really
badly so uh
who I was and my family and like those
memory started coming back within 24
hours I didn't know who I was for about
24 hours
but then everything else started coming
back on it the problem I had was that
you would forget for about about eight
months was that you would speak to me
and I couldn't remember what you just
said and the worst part about it was is
that there was two versions of me there
was a version
it was in it it was just kinda like and
then there was this other version of me
that was sort of somewhat out of the
body still and was aware that what was
happening wasn't right and was like very
ashamed and so there was just like a ton
of depression and anxiety and stress was
dark it was dark it was dark yeah yeah
yeah yeah - be with people but not
remember what they just said to make
social interaction is humiliating Wow
and then finally after he wants it
started coming to where you somehow the
brain maybe came back to the homeostasis
eventually I met a young hippie guy who
taught me that we saw Oh some
neuroscientists and they thought that I
there was like some blood on the brain
and they thought that I was gonna be
pretty much screwed for life and then I
met a hippie guy tell me how to meditate
and and this was like oh yeah and
meditation six months man six months and
all of a sudden it was like whoa better
than it was before at two months in or
eight months in is one uh so I so I met
him this is weird right some reflecting
back knows I met her got the timeframe
off I had to have been so I had in four
months in and then I met him and then it
was his name's Martin and then after my
work with Martin it was about six months
journey of meditation whoa yeah okay
what was he teaching you Oh
the most simple technique just this very
simple mindfulness meditation of being
aware of my breath and you know he used
some pretty simple tactic so like if
thoughts come just use a little hook
that practice alone very simple
no very simple so crazy old me yeah yeah
a thousand year old Perth oh yeah years
old practice could potentially be a
rescue yeah yeah yeah well yeah I mean
it also probably hope that I stop doing
drugs
all the time - I was self-medicating
pretty heavy oh yeah that's help doing
that I wonder how much we weigh each
variable in that scenario is probably a
good amount is the stopping of the yeah
gave that out of the way
well when you can't socialize with
people than the medication
self-medicating is yeah that's all it
was a family shelter you know the dark
man uh but this is like 22 ish that way
- yeah it was uh accident happened about
a month after I was 22 and then you're
you're all then kind of like after ten
months you're like whoa the school I'm
back in this okay then you can do like
end up dedicating your life - oh yeah
what's so passionate man I just I've
been like you look at my bookshelf it's
all just like consciousness healing book
psychology books awareness books all of
it I'm very curious so you know resume
post of the 10 month period and you're
getting it back and you've been curious
reading and well yeah take us to the he
said 10 years of tech startups yeah okay
that led you just sensing yeah so I
didn't go like right into applying tech
to the country space that's been in the
last four years but I started I had a
social media promotions platform back in
2010 and 11 and I rolled that into
Groupon and the early days and I helped
lead the international expansion for a
Groupon throughout Asia in the Middle
East which is really fun in India that
was awesome ah and then after that one I
had I was part of a Y Combinator startup
called Grouper social club which was
really cool as well I got a group thing
going on I don't know that was a
high-growth startup that was fun to be a
part of and then I built up to the team
we helped build a biometric payment
solution for one of the large cruise
lines in Miami where you get chance act
at the blink of an eye and that's
notable because when I was working on
that I met my partner Thomas Kirsten who
was the AI product lead for Xbox
connect damn yeah super smart guy yeah
and he was the one we were doing in our
free time when we're working on that
payment solution we would always talk
about the spirituality and like how
spirituality had helped us so much in
terms of our own healing and personal
development and a question that came up
was you know why are more people
interested in it you know and language
was sort of the answer they showed up in
between us and so we asked the next
question which was like well how can we
create an a direct experience with it
without there having to be language so
someone can actually experience some of
these things that we're talking about my
spiritual language right and I led us to
muscle testing which is what we're doing
which is not a gesture yeah whoa yeah
well I'm not gonna use words anymore to
dive into these speeds spiritual
experience some use muscle yeah and an
embodied experience body experience and
coming into my feelings and I think a
very sage mystic once said Bob Marley is
the mystic but I'm referring to it from
the quote him I hope this is right it
was something the lines of those who
feel it know it yeah Bob Neil tower yeah
yeah yeah okay what are we talking about
the what are we feeling those who feel
it know it I know we're calm words on
yeah visit this unity the
interconnectedness the unbounded love
nests yeah yeah I suppose so right when
I think that's I like the way that you
framed it as a question because it does
seem to be really personal right um and
it's like well what are you experiencing
you know and embracing that yeah and
it's okay but your experience is
different than what I'm experiencing
like that's that's cool yeah like just
being being being with that is
mm yeah so so how is it that we can
deliver this mm-hm
through Scentsy yeah so you know it's so
funny it depends on like the audience
I'm talking to in which path I normally
explain it
um and this is I'm guessing this is a
broader audience er yes yeah so so
there's a very scientific path which we
can go deep um and then there's a
original path and and what we'll start
the original and we can go science yes
please
Chinese medicine for thousands of years
has said that the body has wisdom and
you can consult the body to understand
what's going on and be precise with
healing modalities right so acupuncture
and chiropractor to have work they do
that they do these little muscle tests
would it help to do an example for sure
so a traditional muscle test is they
extend you put this arm down I've put my
hand here to ground me and then the
doctor chiropractor acupuncture will
press you have to resist up oh I'm gonna
reason Christ up just a little bit it's
a very light press like that and what
they're doing is they're looking at the
recoil of the deltoid whoa and they ask
well I should see the deltoid kind of
flex exactly if their stress so there's
stress there's like a wiggle and if
there's no stress its firm and then this
way you're working with the energy of
the body to tailor a diagnostic and what
do you want the deltoid to do that's an
interesting question right because um I
think it would be a mixed response in
who you're talking to you but from the
people who I worked closest with it
tends to be you don't say they want it
do anything you want to observe you just
want to observe what I witnessed yeah
but then is there and I deal that the
body is in the healthy shape that if the
deltoid is doing something it's healthy
right okay yeah I see you again yeah so
um let's go back one step but actually I
missed something that was really
important yeah and sorry about that so
what that's one things I love about
muscle testing an individual doing it is
your question was really good
was what do you want it to do and so
much of our lives were trying to
optimize its outcome and muscle
assessing really requires this like
surrender and openness to what is yeah
and and yeah and I feel like that can
help a lot will help me a lot of just
like letting go of my optimized outcomes
and then your next question which is
also a good one and I think if I
understood it correctly was it are they
in a healthy state yeah do they need to
be and it would help I don't know if
it's necessary I don't have enough
research there to speak to that but
these thousands of years of yeah but but
in those thousands of years what they
say is that if it is in an unhealthy
state we can still muscle tests we can
use it to identify what is at the root
of that so if you're a feeling anxiety
or depressed we can ask questions and
identify the actual emotional stressor
associated with the depressed feeling or
anxious feeling and then by identifying
that you know awareness and itself is a
healing mechanism but also with it we
can take action that's very specific to
what's been identified right okay okay
so there could potentially be some other
sorts of anxieties or other stuff that's
buried in the body and you can
potentially tell by doing these body
exercises that ya can
you can start unpacking what could be
buried in well and it ties into that
common statement of the body doesn't lie
you know everybody holds the score yeah
yeah yeah that's a really good book I
got it ready yet
it's really good yeah how body was asked
or body doesn't line these things we
intuitively know and I'll kind of speak
to you but it's real it's like yeah it's
very real and you can apply that so yeah
so keep walking us down the story yes
yeah well so you can apply that and to
help facilitate your own healing
I was just in the opening ceremony for
this conference and Josh field said
feeling is healing and that couldn't be
more appropriately true for our
technology which is like yeah we've got
to embrace our feelings yes and allow
them to help us see the truth you know
what's really going on yeah yeah but
then there's always the we can't dwell
on feelings and then we can take
ourselves potentially out of some of our
most actualized states as well so it's
kind of a difficult nuanced right yeah
yeah conversation yeah it's so it really
is it's a but it's it's a really good
point and I think it'd be more
appropriate with a question which is
like when I when you when when we
embrace something do we obsess or it
where does obsession occur I don't know
the answer to that but I mmm I wonder
when we embrace and integrate something
do we continue to obsess or is it now a
part of right let's say the thought
arises thought that maybe one that makes
us feel uncomfortable and say and that
we embrace that thought mm for a little
bit and then we see maybe where it goes
for a little bit but then we kind of
want to return back to being in our
maybe our focused state of doing what we
were doing before yeah yeah but so that
is cool I think many people can get
behind that but then sometimes I think
we can too often find ourselves going
into why did I just think that I just
say so so hard right right right
this is such a good distinction yeah
right right and then in that its
resistance its denial of what happened
its rejection of what happened it's like
why I'm questioning and I'm regretting
and shaming myself versus I did that
[ __ ] yeah I love myself yeah yeah and I
and I hope to be able to reflect on what
I did and
and understand that I could potentially
be a better citizen of the planet if I
if I for myself and for my family for my
unity for the whole society okay but yes
two cents keep keep walking us down the
sensi path yeah well this is the path
what you just hit on is like so sage and
that's it okay which is that that's the
part that we really want to get to you
which is that how I treat myself is a
reflection of how I'm going to treat my
family and how I'm going to treat
society and I don't want to treat my
environment and it starts right here
with the connection to our heart and our
feelings so if I'm in rejection of my
feelings and you show up and you're
crying I'm like this is like this guy I
don't have I haven't given it to myself
and I can't give to you what I haven't
received and so embracing my feelings
and integrating them becomes this
ability to now connect with you like
this right and like be here together
okay interesting so and so sorry so
going back to sense you we can put this
in a way where this can tackle a lot of
the issues that we face I hope so this
is in its best especially in San
Francisco we kind of have a serious
amount of people that are on the streets
yeah and that when we can potentially
reflect on what's going on how can it's
this is very complicated but there may
be something that you're saying that
that could help us and Drive a little
bit more empathy and love and compassion
towards the the stories the situation's
the stimuli that got people into the
scenarios that they're in and so yeah
yeah yeah yes this is a big one yeah
someone walks up to you and it and
they're crying or if someone's crying if
someone the etc and we
done a self-work practice or where we
are very comfortable with our own crying
and moan or will be harder for us to
attend other people ain't crying this is
very good stuff yeah right okay yeah
yeah yeah and more people own so to tie
that into sensor you go back to your
point ah more people and smartphones and
health insurance so like being able to
administer the muscle test with a
smartphone provides the capacity to help
point a person back to start here I'm
the US are in the world globally
globally more people in a smartphone oh
oh that question sorry I I the initial
data hell and that was in the u.s. that
makes that makes it makes it yeah yeah
ok so then so then what are we using
sensors in the phone to be able to
direct us back yeah ok so they're going
back to the test so I did the muscle
test the way it works is we were talking
about is the recoil in the deltoids and
the key part is the recoil okay and so
knowing that we asked the question which
is okay well how do we replicate that
recoil without a doctor being present
and so we created I'm gonna grab my
phone yeah please yes we created a
unique whipping gesture turn my screen
off a whipping gesture so it's actually
three whips you go one two three and we
get three peaks of data from the
gyroscope and accelerometer and what
we're measuring is the recoil of the
hand whoa all throughout the wrist the
hand and the forearm are muscles and
what do you what can you learn from just
yeah three whips that's a well what
that's okay so there's two parts that
there's what we're detecting which i
think is what you're asking about but
then there's how can that be applied by
a lot of different modalities yeah yeah
and the first one we're detecting is
binary it's either stress or no stress
really and that's what we can
white level of binary what okay so what
is it about this whip that you can
determine a binary dresser muscular
tension so and are you asking about how
we initially identified the same page so
is this like is this like when I when
I'm holding it I'm tense I'm whipping it
all tense and then that's like yo this
person stress yeah and what's
interesting about that is that you could
be like around heads are you trying to
force it and you're not really tense if
you're not actually really tense
oh sorry if you're not actually tense
will pick up and not actually be intense
so you literally have to be really tense
you can't fake it can't fake it
yeah okay so then yeah because even when
I was trying to do that I was loose but
I was faking exists I saw that in your
hand like yeah and like and you can you
can fake it to the point where you'll be
able to evoke some tension but there has
to be even if you faked it there has to
be the felt experience versus if you're
like light as a feather right just like
trying to be like I'm ten something like
you're super loose it's the body your
body Dexter since he's literally just
asking me hey will you whip your phone
three times right now yeah and I'm like
okay one two three and I whip it and
then you guys are like oh you show a
stress level of blank it stress no
stress by there but the one part that's
important is its specific to thought so
the way sensitive works let me show a
demo but now let's show this yeah cool
so so for context we just we announced
this yet this app just hit the App Store
last week last week grant it's been
we've been doing research for three
years so we had a research platform and
the seniors of yeah that's what it takes
to get the good stuff down to the Y yeah
so this is it oh that game yeah what
[ __ ] song yeah let's bring let's bring
it up yeah let's bring it up to this one
and go ahead and that's the dashboard
page and the top to the first Button
says measure how you feel okay so to you
just hop on that button immediately you
can check
your current state but it prompts you
with a question it says think and feel
I can stress my life I can I can
hopefully manage it has a specific
statement you have to thinking you'll
and then manage stress live better yeah
practice mind and body skills are
focused on improving specific areas of
your life how do you feel so then you
click on that to check in regularly you
have manage your health yes you tap on
this okay how do you feel and then
there's the statement I'm able to
effectively respond to the stress in my
life and if you shake the phone a little
bit you'll see the sensor data movement
so just shake the phone a little bit
move it a little bit yeah yeah you can
see the sensor movement yeah so that's
the gyroscope that's the joyous cope
yeah so we visualize this gyroscope and
accelerometer data both yeah use both
our primary signal came from the
gyroscope but your honor it comes from
gyroscope so yeah there it is so uh so I
will I have to be with this so I focus
on the statement thinking failure
response I'm able to effectively respond
to stress in my life I swipe and then I
wit and I went three times and then it
processes the sensor data whoa no no
one's using it so it's gonna take a
second for the signal but if you it'll
show up in about a second or two you've
got to turn the servers on they're just
feeling stressed I'm a little nervous
when I do public speaking so pretty
accurate and so we'll just show you just
like that and then you can agree
disagree yeah so feels really agree
after reflecting yeah and that's the non
conscious part so they agree after
reflecting is our sort of that button is
our measurement I'm starting to see how
many people were giving nice insights to
into like something they weren't aware
of oh I see yeah so the intention of
that third button okay and I'll agree
and now the cool thing is right so now
we've identified that I'm in somewhat of
a stress state it says explore sources
of stress so now we can identify where
it's coming from down find a safe space
take a deep breath so here's kind of
some of the things that you can do
afterward yeah interesting and then it
shows up green if I do that in the don't
detects tree yeah exactly
and so explore work is the first topic
and now I can explore if it's coming
from work what I'm gonna do is go back
to our dashboard page and these are all
the topics so it you can explore these
topics
where the stress is coming from Oh
interesting okay that was nice check-in
from yesterday okay so so that so the
topic options okay and then so then what
you do is you can look at work finance
well-being self-esteem joy intimacy
family flow autonomy random so then when
I let's say click on intimacy that is
the do I does that mean I have to be in
like an intimate moment or if I'm in
work I have to be at work and then I'm
measuring it no that's a good question
but it's let's click on intimacy so
intimacy opens up and it tells you how
to set context to be in a neutral state
um you just have to think about that toe
so I think I think my intimate
relationships are healthy focus on the
statement think and feel your response
and then you swipe and WIPP three times
when ready okay nice nice so um so each
one of those cards has their own
sentence that's like my work is healthy
or my intimacy is healthy and then
depending on on on if that statement is
is true to you folks don't say anything
official swipe and whip three times
already
okay my answer relationships were
healthy okay so I'll focus on it feel it
okay okay and you whip so I swiped whip
one two three that's fitted to me but
let's see if this is accurate does that
feel true it's okay
it says stress not it's the stress not
detected
I've been sacrificing a lot of what I've
been working on with intimate
relationships for what we're building
with the show so but but at the same
time I do have healthy intimate
relationships so also this is um you
would want to do this on your own phone
because you guys sure this is on your
phone you need to me when you sign up
there's demographic information you give
that help with the precision of our
signal so interesting so you might get a
better insight I would overall agreed
cool yeah both agree that Oh tap agree
feedback great job managing this part of
your life interesting okay cool okay so
there's there's these topics okay
interesting so then what am i what am i
that this just gives me a more
instantaneous response into feedback a
closed back loop into how I'm managing
my stress in air in each one of those
topics of my life
and it should a percentage of the time
help you potentially identify an area
you might not be aware of that's a
source of stress and I'm really glad you
hid intimate relationships because that
was one in our early research that I hit
on that was like an eye-opener for me so
we had a baby I love so much my name's
charlie
and congratulations Charlie Charlie it's
a girl and she's the joy of my life and
gets on the locks
yeah I'm screwed oh that's it's like a
couple years older like what I had one
hour but the point is that um so about
six months after she was born I was
exploring the protocol on intimate
relationships and I you know I did the
statement I did the gesture
it says stress not detected and
immediately my monkey brain was like I'm
sorry says stress detected and that's
what I said immediately my my monkey
brain was like oh that's not true I want
to shut it down and then I stopped for a
second I was like no it totally is true
it's been like six months and I've
totally neglected my wife since you've
had the baby and I was completely
unaware of it and like there was total
stress building between her and I that
like I'm pretty sure if they kept going
would turn into something gnarly yeah
but in that moment I stopped and I went
talk to her I told her I was like look I
just saw stress detected on internet
relationships like how are you feeling
and she's like yeah I definitely feel
stressed or do you I'm like holy [ __ ]
I've had a conversation and it literally
transformed my relationship in that
moment because we also went and changed
it you know and you know got deep and
intimate with each other and yeah damn
and I wasn't aware I really wasn't aware
I'm confident it would have went on that
path of like you know Oh interesting so
so there's a couple things here so first
is that it it dude doing doing our life
trajectories can go so many different
ways and if we think sometimes
things may be going smoothly perfectly
fine but we don't necessarily know that
the way that we actually are with right
one of our loved ones can be on a
trajectory that might not be so healthy
so to be able to check in like this yeah
and yeah push put ourselves on to a
healthier trajectory yeah it's awesome I
think it's like so in the you I love the
way you describe that that was perfectly
put because the way you describe that is
it's so well to how fast life is moving
and as a function of the speed of our
life we stuff things down mmm and then
we light it without I don't know I wish
there's a better word for it but we lie
to ourselves as I say it we let
ourselves as a mechanism to help
ourselves with efficiency mmm I realize
just fine uh-huh let's keep God out of
time for that right now so let's keep
going and you know and and we buy it we
believe that you know and damn the pace
of life is creating potentially no time
for feeling right I said that one now
yeah even though it's my wife like
that's literally what my monkey brain
wanted was hey yeah it's like stressed
oh I have to get back to work yeah but
she's fine look dad intimate moment
there in six months like what you know
it's crazy anyways in six months but it
was long it's a good yeah that's a good
check-in yeah system I did your body and
that's the point
the real technology is your body and
that's really what we're looking to do
is sense he is we're amplifying
something that's already there which is
your feelings you know and that's what
we're really looking to carry the flag
on is like look we got to come back into
this you know we got to come back into
this and find a way to love it and
embrace it
so that we can integrate it and
live healthy for a lot of reasons damn
our emotions regulate our immune system
being one of them right like it's a
whole nother conversation but so the
more we get into our feelings and
learning our emotions a bit more we're
able to manage our health more
appropriately right more effectively I
should say potentially yeah this is a
this is a physical way to measure with
using technology the current state of
our relationship with work or with
intimacy or how you feel how you feel I
feel it so that application you just saw
were those things and we're starting
there but then what we're doing is we're
also working with different researchers
and healers because there's a lot of
really powerful healing techniques that
use muscle testing they require a doctor
to be present and now we can take those
techniques and meet a much larger
audience at scale and so it's how you
feel because they're using the felt
experience to identify the root cause of
a stressor I can give examples on yeah
yeah so there's a doctor she's our
scientific adviser now out of Oxford
University
her name is dr. Ann Jensen she did her
whole PhD at Oxford on muscle testing
whoa yeah yeah she's amazing yeah yeah a
lot of ways she's amazing she's like
four masters like two postgrads
chiropractor she's just an amazing woman
she's so smart so she also has a program
called heart speak and heart speak uses
muscle testing to identify if stress is
present based on a certain topic so for
work for example and then identify what
the emotional causes of that stressor is
it anger is it fear is it sadness
there's like seven different emotions it
goes through and then once it's
identified the emotion with the muscle
test she then uses a posture based
exercise to evoke the stressful emotion
so let's say anger is identified with
work you come forward into a ball you
use the posture of anger your hands are
gonna fist grimacing the face
and you start creating the emotion of
anger and what's interesting is you feel
it burning off as you're revoking it so
you feel anger you're slowly burning off
and then once it's cleared you sit up
and you smile and you pivot to joy every
stressful emotion has a different non
stressful emotion that it pivots to you
and when you're pivoting to joy your
smile and your shoulders are rolling
back your hands are open you're
rewriting the memory of work from anger
to joy using the process of memory
reconsolidation how memory works so that
you can be a working no longer feel
stressed well your technique is so
powerful it's changed my life would we
also want to change work though to work
that we are more passionate about doing
right that's a great question and for
sure and I think another question that
would follow is would you have a would
you be more effective at making the
decision with a clear mind right you
sort of instead of making the decision
out of reaction day that's that's great
yeah so then you can be clear be clear
like oh you're this is [ __ ] my bosses
abusing me I need to get out of here so
you can measure the the state of the
feeling of the body so sure work is
measuring the stay of the feeling of the
body
she's antennae buying muscle tension my
muscle test yeah which part of the body
uh well so she does this test phone in
her manual work she's currently doing
this okay and she's asking the question
is it anger it's fear actually says it's
it's anger it's fear it's sadness oh one
week it's whatever they stress you
follow that and you clear that you clear
that emotion so sadness was identified
you come forward and i evoke sadness and
then we retest sadness if it's been
identified as stress then yeah okay or
anger or whatever whatever emotions been
identified and then you can go through a
memory reconsolidation the process
process that uses posture to Moses
posture yet to clear a stressful motion
and then pivot it to a beneficial
emotion so sad so it's so for sadness
you actually forward your hands or your
faces in their hands and your shoulders
are rounding your whole body sort of
going
that posture will actually can trigger
the feeling of sadness and then so you
reflect on that for a moment and then
you transition to yeah it's less about
reflecting we don't want to think about
the emotion we want to feel it we want
to feel it superficially uses the right
brain left brain and we want with left
brain too so the logical side right
sighs the intuitive emotional feel
inside we really want to get into the
felt experience and not be thinking
about it you a try
sure so okay do you one do one yeah
let's do it so that I'm sure finder
technique so let's do it so just uncross
your legs okay okay yeah yeah yes so uh
similar to the muscle test so um bring
to mind something that's stressful in
your life at the moment whatever it is
you have to talk to me about it or tell
me about okay just think about it all
right
when it's present and you few of the
feelings of stress let me know I you
know we I wouldn't write into it we have
to test something first say out loud
where do you live
Oh San Francisco say I live in San
Francisco I live in San Francisco we say
stop into my end okay is that okay yeah
okay say I live in San Fran I live in
San Francisco say I live in Tokyo I live
in Tokyo
okay okay yeah you feel silly yeah it's
like right at that's a stealth
experience the body's like no no I don't
look at a ffunny right embodied
experience this is just ridiculous
but with you what did you feel when I
what did you feel when I there was a
wave of you so there's a in your
shoulder there's a slight recoil in
there when you said I'm in San Francisco
there wasn't and you're good to go oh
interesting there's a recoil yeah her
toes are bounce a little bit and I'm
using that you felt it at the same
pressure on both it's like oh it's like
yeah yeah I'm not pregnant I felt a
recoil - yeah yeah and so now what I
just did was a calibration so it's
basically the body will hold the score
and be like I don't
yeah why don't we think oh this is
[ __ ] yeah what are you talking about
your whole [ __ ] you AMA you say even
laughing it's just really cool to see so
I asked those two questions to calibrate
and see because sometimes you can be in
a state that it's it's flipped
which is interesting or you can be in a
flipped state uh yeah it's like oh yeah
we don't
why just what percentage of people are
somewhere between like 15 and 20 I would
say and then you can also be sort of in
a fried state so if you're like
dehydrated or super overtired like just
not gonna work oh yeah yeah so that's
why I calibrated with okay see if you're
yeah that was the calibration oh yeah
okay so now you want me to push back
yeah it's just that like we little bit
oh that's good now bring to mine
whatever it is that's stressful in your
life whatever the topic might be okay
stress is present is it let me know if
it is take your time okay so really be
with it
so whatever the topic is bring it to
mind okay all right yeah it's present
all right it's just present yeah good
okay on a scale of one to ten ten being
the most severe what would you rate it
five a five okay cool because the stress
is anger the cause of stress is fear the
cause of stress is we're gonna fear so
we're gonna do heart speak light and so
we go through quickly calm 3-sphere so
if a fear it's a little bit you're come
forward into a ball okay you place your
hands are you're facing your hands make
sure we're in the shot yeah okay so come
forward into like right there your I see
the camera you're in the shot okay so
but really put your face in your hands
okay use your facial okay okay I want
you to feel comfortable so using the
ability mmm okay doing it yes so I'm
gonna guide you through it so there's no
need to know why you're afraid now
that's not important it's the feeling
that's important letting go of any
thoughts about fear I'm just allowing
yourself to have the felt experience of
fear will use the posture of fear so
sort of burying your face into your
hands trying to hide almost allowing the
shoulders to round letting the body go
weak allowing any sort of facial
expression that might be natural for you
to evoke the feeling of fear whatever
your face might look like when you're
afraid allow that facial expression to
occur
be brave there's no need to know why
we're afraid that's not important now
it's just the feeling search every cell
tissue and organ of your body for the
feeling of fear keep searching for it
keep looking for it
the feelings of fear may come in waves
as they start to subside take a breath
and look again using the whole posture
the whole body of the face so expression
to evoke the feeling of fear this is
your time to clear it be with it allow
it to be felt through the whole body
keep it focus and when you reach the
point where you feel like fear has been
cleared take a breath and look one more
time scanning the whole body mmm yes you
are in of the body keep looking for it
and once you feel like the feelings of
fear are clear you can sit up with your
eyes closed but really take your time to
be with it stay with your eyes closed
we'll roll the shoulders back
now instead of fear reach inside and
find the central column of knowing it's
always there inside reach in and find it
enjoy it allow this feeling of knowing
to permeate every cell tissue and organ
of your body feeling it from the top of
your head through your shoulders your
heart solar plexus down through your
stomach into your hips your thighs you
shouldn't your calf your toes
allow the feeling of knowing to watch
all through your body and when you're
good there you can blink your eyes open
yeah how was it yeah good stuff good so
a scale of one to ten what would you
rate it now whatever that topic was
whatever that topic was how do I rate it
now in terms of what how stressful how
stress it's a little back to it and all
about it oh yeah how stressful it is
yeah now
yeah just shoulder so resistant to my
head present okay resist so yeah and
just think about the topic okay let me
know when the felt experience is there
when you have it present okay it's
president okay stress present I mean
yeah there was a little bit but we could
go again but yeah it looked way from her
yeah yeah the yeah the I think probably
one of the most interesting aspects to
that is yet come closer yeah sorry about
that actually yeah you're good you're
good they're probably one of the most
interesting aspects of that is the
diving deep into the feeling in the body
of whatever the thing was that you that
we decided to explore it all right so
what is it what is that thing and then
the scanning of the body for where that
thing is mm-hmm and you're like okay
feel it deeper okay feeling deeper
I feel deeper and then it's like well
where you where is it yeah we're right
right and then it's the process like
it's non-existent yeah yeah yeah so kind
of you can go through maybe a process of
identifying okay well I had the thought
maybe I had the feeling but then I'm
scanning for it and where is it yeah and
then when that that sort of central
column of millions of knowing yeah
knowing was in in many ways it's like
like that's destiny in a sense is that
maybe that central column of knowing is
that everything is perfect exactly the
way it is yeah yeah and how wonderful is
that
yeah what is this fear nonsense if
everything is perfect the way that it is
and that that you're meant to uncover
that moment exactly when you're meant to
uncover it with you and your wife yeah
that's right and and then so that
technique that we're doing manually we
can now do a sensing so to your point in
our future release that will be in there
as a healing modality so that on your
own instead of having a doctor to the
muscle test you know if you're
identified that intimacy is a place of
stress I can now identify the emotional
cause clear it on the other side of that
maybe have but confidence or courage to
go and speak to my wife about what's
going on yeah right or whatever it is
that's going on but by be clearing the
emotional state we then have this
presence where we can do anything yeah
correct correct
you need the this this practice well not
only of wanting to dive deeper into the
current state that we're feeling since
it's our our desire to actually open up
sensi and go through that process but
also then of this this clearing the a
feeling of being cleared so that you can
make these confidence
moves in the direction of of doing
something like healing oh yeah yeah yeah
that's yeah did the whole process is a
process of its process it's a
vulnerability a process of in many ways
confidence you have to be vulnerable to
go through this process then you have to
be confident to take action on on how
you want to make that change and then
realizing that that feedback loop that
you're going through is potentially
unlocking new states of consciousness
states of being for you new yeah fruits
yeah for you so yeah thank you yeah it's
great yeah good stuff three years of
research to lead into even the first
yeah developments of the application and
yeah well we just did a lot of different
a lot of that research was understanding
how muscle testing can be applied so we
did research with like everything from
employee surveys food allergies to
positive psychology and meditation
techniques and we did some work with dr.
Martin finders Corey's here we love him
yeah dude
what's the so what's what so what's the
the idea is that before I am my body was
keeping the score and was like no you
actually like feel quite a bit towards
that thing you I was set five right yeah
there and then at afterward the body was
like maybe a tiny bit but you're much
more like yeah so you felt less of us
yeah I mean the first one there was a
deep it was a deep wiggle and then the
second one there was a little wiggle
scene and so there's still something so
the must so the muscle Wiggles yet will
recoil the muscle recoils out when
there's a lie um this is complex when we
get any of this level to be yeah yeah
when there's strengthen there's stress
under stress this is well documented in
physiology you pick up a weight the
weights too heavy
how did you know that way it was too
heavy when you put it down we don't ever
stop
that's that question we're just like I
knew it was too heavy right there's a
tendon in your body that connects
everywhere there's muscle fiber
there's Golgi tendon that's the name of
the tendon Golgi tendons connect muscle
fiber the skeletal wall it is a sensory
organ that's an attender that's also a
sensory organ the Golgi tendon has
something called the Golgi reflex so
when there's too much stress or tension
on muscle fiber the Golgi tendon recoils
and that sends a neuromuscular signal to
the brain saying too much stress and
tension put down the physical weight now
think about psychologically when you're
stressed in tents right the body's
flexing and you're literally or there's
tension right and your stress and
tensors tension and it's the body
sending a signal to the brain saying
whatever you're doing stop we don't
listen to it right we push through it we
get sick we get ill we get into fights
all kind of thing right boom if you slow
down and listen to the body when it
whispers we don't have to crumble when
it's screaming right which is sickness
and interesting right so we're going to
listen to the subtle feelings of our
body we can be guided by what might be
optimal for us in our health in sort of
the premises whoa okay so you have
subtle signals of the body rather than
the crumbling that happens when it's
screaming right so so so listening to
the whispers of when you have something
psychologically or physically that is so
hard that's our yeah stressful yeah okay
and then yeah okay
okay so sense see where can people go to
explore sense ah thanks the App Store so
just go after we're now on Android and
we're on iOS C and s ie yes sense just
search sense just sense you'll be the
first anxious okay great on iOS and
Android and what is this is this is so
much more to unpack love to do more
conversation about the subnet and the
domain also is sensi oh it's actually
since the app sense yep calm okay sensi
app.com SE NS IE app calm and search for
sensi in the app stores I want to ask
you do you think we're in a simulation
oh wow that's a big question
it does feel that way doesn't it that's
the Wow do we have another hour I wonder
that a very often I I it's a good
question and one that I I feel like
there's smarter people in this
conference that might be able to address
that better than me but I do really
wonder that what do you thinks the most
beautiful thing in the world what's
inside of us what's our way I'm gonna
start to cry what's in our hearts what
if what's here otherwise they're crying
there is something here when we embrace
our bodies that is so beautiful oh so
beautiful man these are tears of joy
yeah it's just so beautiful and I
rejected my body for so long and the
sooner I started to embrace it the more
of this and by the way this feels so
good
I might be crying but it's like tears of
joy and bliss it's like whatever is here
is making a mess now but yeah that yes
yeah
yeah Wow you're the right question to
ask me it was a good question it's like
I want some of that yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's like hain't tapping in like that
yeah Wow Wow I really like that question
by the way good start asking Mauro that
everyone that question I love that one
to stand on the shoulders of giants yeah
this has been such a pleasure thank you
likewise coming on the show thank you a
huge book Wow Joanne yeah yeah Congrats
on all the work
thanks sensei thanks man everyone check
out since you let us know your thoughts
in the comments below check out the link
to sensi as well in the comments below
geek conversing more with your parents
your family your co-workers the people
online on social media get talk to them
more about how we can feel and how we
can identify these sources of stress
better using technologies like sensi and
support consciousness hacking support
simulation our links are below support
organizations to entrepreneurs the
artists around the world that you
believe in and go and build the future
everyone manifest your dreams into the
world thank you so much for tuning in
and we will see you soon
awesome